I'm selling a ton of [ __ ] in a b2b
environment by following the people that
I want to sell to on social networks and
figuring out what they like in the world
besides being who they are as a
professional and reverse engineering and
exploiting their passions as a way to
sell them so in real English I mean go
follow people on Twitter and if they're
into fishing talk to them about fishing
and then sell them your SAS product I
listen and it's confusing because I'm a
paradox that way because I talk so much
but it's only after I've listened to
fully I've literally been watching
everybody to the scale of my human
capabilities for three years on their
behavior on snapchat that's why I feel
like I'm ready to talk I mean the b2b
stuff is a [ __ ] money pit it's
amazing like I think I I have no empathy
for you guys I think it's super easy
compared to me to say I'm being thin
serious you know what Stan that [ __ ]
Ogilvy or you know it's Rick at AT&T
this shouldn't be that hard and more
importantly what you have to do is you
have to eliminate romance you have to
understand what they care about more
than what you care about and that's just
a common mistake of sales people like no
[ __ ] you're trying to hit your numbers
and do your thing but if you know what
their rationale is to why they're not
using you you need to exploit that you
need to figure out what that
vulnerability is and explain that to
them so I'm just reverse engineering at
scale it's why I prep for zero meanings
you know it's zero prep I'm gonna listen
like never like I have to walk in and
listen for a little bit and then I'll
know what to do by the end up on them
before and you're not checking out their
social cause that kind of stuff Europe
no not not if it's a real pit like I let
me know the answer's no
you